let's go to Richard from Jersey Richard
welcome to the program
hello David Pleasures they'd be speaking
with you the pleasure is all mine
so
um the thing on my mind right now
um I think a thing on a lot of people's
mind right now is for thinking it had to
be 2024 election and it seems to me that
the writing is on the wall I love the
status is more than likely going to be
the Republican nomination
and I keep thinking about the prospects
of Biden basic law detectives and that
just seems to me like it's cool we're
starting to lose you the audio wasn't
great to start with it started at like a
six and a half but you're quite
literally just fading and cutting out
now so I heard you say you think
DeSantis will be the nominee for the
Republicans it's certainly possible I
don't know yet it's too early for me to
say that you were then starting to talk
about Biden and I just couldn't hear a
word you were saying
okay does that sound better yes it does
beautiful so my main thing is I don't
think
Biden is gonna win against Rhonda
Sanchez okay but it's he's still toting
the line of saying that he is going to
run and the more time that goes on it
seems that he's going to so I'm
wondering what your thoughts are on is
it possible for him to change vice
presidency choice because Kamala Harris
herself isn't very popular either is it
possible to get a more exciting younger
Progressive candidate on the ticket with
him that could possibly bolster his
chances okay this is a good question if
Biden runs could he and should he
replace Kamala Harris his current VP
with someone else he absolutely could I
think the problem with that is whatever
benefit Biden might get from as you say
a more exciting or likable VP running
made in 24 could very easily be canceled
out by the fact that bailing on your VP
for consecutive terms might be seen as a
sign of trouble in Paradise for lack of
a better term so I don't know if I were
advising Biden that I would say to do
that I think you want to project
stability you want to project a steady
hand and part of that would be this this
is a good team and even if people are
changing behind the scenes you go with
the with the the person who is currently
VP also it would be very strange and
difficult and awkward to be campaigning
for several months while Kamala Harris
is still president with somebody else as
the running mate I think it raises I
think it creates problems for Biden to
do that
okay I I take your point that it would
be awkward but
I I my main thing with Biden is always
is that he's very low energy and even
though we were able to get past the
midterms pretty well I think it would
have been better if we had had a
president and a vice president that
inspires people to vote for something
instead of voting against the greater
evil and I I just I'm looking for things
that Democrats can do to do that for
younger voters and you know voters in
general I agree with you generally I
don't know that replacing Kamala is that
thing but I appreciate the the idea
fair enough thanks for speaking with me
David all right thank you for calling in
that's Richard from Jersey very very
powerful declarations there